قد نشتري اللحوم وربما لا نشتريها اذ
ارتفع سعرها قد ناكل الدجاج اليوم ولكن
اذا وصل لاسعار جنونيه نستطيع الاستغناء
عنه لفتره ولكن هناك وجبات لا يمكن
للمصريين التخلي عنها والكشري على راسها
[موسيقى]
المزيج بين الارز والمكرونه والعدس والدقه
والتقليه هو مفضل لدى احفاد الفراعنه وجزء
اصيل من هويتهم وثقافتهم الغذائيه كما انه
اقل سعرا مقارنه ببقيه الوجبات الاخرى
ولكن مع ارتفاع سعر كل مكوناته ضمن
تداعيات الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وانعكاسها على الاقتصاد العالمي انضم
لقائمه الممنوعات عند كثير من الطبقات غير
القادره حاليا على تناوله كل ما اشتهته
[موسيقى]
اصغر طبق كشري كان يتراوح سعره بين السبعه
والعشره جنيهات منذ شهور اصبح الان يبلغ
سعره 15 جنيها اي ان رب الاسره اذا اراد
شراء اصغر اطباق الكشري لاسرته المكونه من
زوجته وطفلين سيدفع 60 جنيها بدلا من 28
جنيها ارتفاع بمعدل يتعدل 50%
وفي هذا الاطار لا يقع ضرر فقط على
المستهلك فاصحاب مطاعم الكشري ايضا يعانون
من تراجع نسبه المستهلكين مما يعرض
موظفيهم لخطر الاستغناء او قرار غلق
المطعم الى اشعار اخر لصباح العربيه ندى
حجازي القاهره